please these gays they're trying to
murder me
make it be safe well you know it's been
a few days since season two finale of
The White Lotus but T is continuing to
be spilled from Jennifer Coolidge Aubry
Plaza and more of the show's Stars about
everything that went down in that finale
episode now if you haven't had a chance
to catch up on the hit HBO show this is
a spoiler warning
you're an idiot the biggest reveal from
the episode was obviously finding out
which hotel guest was murdered and sadly
Jennifer coolidge's character Tony McCoy
didn't make it out of Sicily alive
you've got this
but in a new interview with the New York
Times Jennifer shared that she never
wanted her character to check out of the
White Lotus saying quote you can't talk
Mike White out of anything really but
whenever Mike was in a really good mood
and laughing about something I'd go like
I don't have to die right Jennifer
shared that she continued to advocate
for her character and explain it's just
really part of her job adding quote
that's an actress fighting for another
season I wanted to be practical in case
Mike had a change of heart I just wanted
to leave the possibilities open
oh my god
um
Tanya oh my God uh
Porsche meet me in termina we gotta get
out of here Creator Mike White also told
the New York Times that following the
wild season two finale where Tanya
gunned down everyone on board the yacht
in Palermo before accidentally falling
into a dinghy and dying he started to
have second thoughts about killing off
the fan favorite character saying quote
Jennifer's the reason I did White Lotus
in the first place because I just wanted
to write something for her and I just
adore her so it's sad I didn't realize
until yesterday but now I am sad it's
going to be hard to do it without her I
really just want to get back to my hotel
oh no are you bored of us no Fez also
had some burning questions about Harper
and Cameron's hookup and Aubry Plaza
visited Seth Meyers to clear up the
rumors I know what happened okay and
what happened is
we did some stuff okay
and I hate it every minute of it okay
good it was disgusting
and there was no penetration oh wow I
don't know and what happened between
Daphne and Ethan on that island well
Megan Bay told variety that although she
doesn't know exactly what played out
between them something explicit
definitely took place adding I think
Daphne just saw this broken man and
wanted to do something to make him feel
more empowered in her own strange way I
really don't think that she led him
there to get back at Cameron or Harper